hello i'm christopher hine and today
we're going to be talking about uh sorry
still still working on the intro and it
gets me every time today we're going to
be talking a little more about the
internal power thing and uh today we're
going to talk about connecting to force
so what it is to connect to force um
there's lots of little subtle ways that
this happen
understand if you can connect to
whatever's making the force you will
seem much stronger because
the act of putting force into you will
disrupt what is forcing you and so
then that will make the force weaker and
you are attached to the stability of the
force and the force needs its own
stability in order to move you so it
gets crazy real quick so i'm going to
show you a couple ways that that happens
today i think this is a pretty deceptive
one most everything happens with
leverage and force angle which are the
first two i covered this is another one
that really does end up using leverage
and force angle in in in a few ways but
actually connecting to the force is a
different principle and there's lots of
cool ways we can use that so i'm going
to talk about that today i'm going to
get josh over here we're going to go to
work josh
[Music]
[Applause]
me
[Music]
all right let's continue our part three
of uh internal power and what internal
power is um and and understand that
these things that i'm showing you
they're principles that can be used i
feel like a lot of times they're used a
little nefariously and and people are
using them to deceive other people and
make people think that you know they
have powers that they don't have
all of the stuff that i'm showing these
demonstrations is accessible to anyone
it's accessible to you right now right
so if you understand the demonstrations
i'm giving you can do these things right
now
there's a little bit of skill that can
be built with them that you know you can
use them
a little better as you practice them
more and also you know once you
understand the principle you can apply
that principle to
situations that are of martial context
but
most of these things are already at play
right so when you see sport martial
artists fighting in the mma ring they're
not unaware of these things they might
not understand them on an intellectual
level but they are unconsciously using
these things all the time right so
okay the one we're gonna talk about
today is connecting to force or
sometimes i say connecting to force
structure because that's what you're
doing you're connecting to the structure
that's making the force right um these
two things i'm going to show are really
highly into the the tricky area so i'm
going to show you two real tricky
versions and then i'm going to show you
a regular version that's used in
wrestling all the time right so
constantly used in wrestling okay so uh
before i showed you how with force angle
we could give you the deception that if
joshua's trying to push me over right
and he's a big guy and he's stronger
than me does that and he tries to push
me over and i change the direction of
his force angle all of a sudden i seem
real strong and stand on one leg and all
this kind of stuff right so that's
because i'm i'm going at a different
angle to his force that's distracting
his force and doing all kinds of kinds
of cool stuff there's another way i can
do that that seems like maybe i've i
it's impossible to do what i just did so
if josh put his hands on my shoulders
right and josh goes to push into me he's
going to push real strong okay now josh
pushing hard and i'm standing right here
look at josh is starting to fall over
but i'm not i'm i'm stable on one leg so
how am i doing it i'm doing a very
similar thing and the way i'm doing is
i'm connecting to him right and so i'll
get all the advantages of force
angle plus i'll kind of get some of
these advantages of the connecting to
force structure so when he pushes into
me all i do is i put my hand up
underneath his arm right here so when he
when josh pushes into me this is what
happens to me as he pushes me right
so when he does that he's now pushing
into himself and you see him like as he
pushes real hard he'll start to lose
balance and all kinds of stuff because
i'm connecting to him so he's actually
disrupting his own balance by pushing
into me so he's using his own force to
destroy his own balance right
and i am borrowing from that because i'm
connected to him so i do have to have
somewhat of a strong arm to connect to
that but once i do that i'm really
really in a stable position now this is
used deceptively all the time there was
a video that circled around maybe eight
nine years ago that was a internal
martial art master and he had this
really big power lifter guy trying to
push him around and the power lifter
couldn't push him and all the people who
are into internal power were saying like
oh see this is real proof here because
that guy's a real strong guy and he
can't push him over and i told them all
that it was this and they said oh no
it's not so i made him a video
explaining this and they said oh it's
not that and then i took the video and i
circled where the guy was doing it and
they said oh it's not that and so it's
like you know at a certain point people
just will believe whatever they want to
believe but this is a way you can show
that and it's just connecting to force
structure and that's a deceptive way you
can show it okay another way you can
show it is and real quick i'm just going
to prove so if i want to pick up josh i
can pick him up right okay so no big
deal i can totally get him up now when i
go to pick up josh josh going to put his
hands on my elbows uh from underneath
and he's just going to push up against
me okay now i'm going to try to lift him
exactly the same
[Music]
and now i'm i swear i'm using absolutely
all my strength that was exerting and
and i still can't get him right and it
feels like he is so much heavier now
there's a couple things at play here
right one is leverage there's leverage
at play because when josh connects to my
elbows i can't line myself up right to
get a nice angle to have a zero zero
lever angle that i can be strong and
then two he's connected to me so when
i'm pushing up i'm actually pushing up
against myself like this right so i'm
i'm putting myself into a crummy
position
by doing that so i can't get underneath
and lift him up now i have done this in
crowds of people i had a little student
who was like five foot nothing maybe 90
pounds and i would have some big burly
guy pick her up and everyone go yeah of
course and then do this and the burly
guy would grunt and strain and not be
able to get her up and everyone be like
oh my god they've got such amazing
powers
so that's a demonstration that can be
done and then i of course explain to all
my students immediately how that works i
didn't tell the people in the
demonstration i wanted to come to the
dojo but
so there's nothing illegitimate about
the fact that that is something that
does happen and that's a way you can use
that and i'll show you right now how
it's done legitimately all the time but
it seems like that shouldn't be possible
it seems like that's something
miraculous and so they must have some
mysterious power they're just connecting
to the structure of the force right okay
now here's a way that this is used in
wrestling all the time right so in
wrestling if someone got a position like
this they pick someone up right if josh
grapevine's around my leg wraps around
my leg and josh is pushing his leg
forward as i go to lift josh feels like
josh weighs a ton and it's super super
hard to get him up because he connected
to me so he connected to the structure
that's making the force and so it makes
it really really hard for me to lift him
now that technique's practiced all the
time in greco-roman wrestling all kinds
of wrestling styles to grape find
someone and connect to the structure
that's making the force and it makes you
really heavy hard to pick up hard to
move around it's really useful skill so
it's used legitimately all the time is
something that exists in martial arts
but is sometimes shown in demonstrations
to look like more than it actually is um
and if someone's really trying to trick
you with that and tell you that you know
the only way you're gonna get that is
meditate on a mountain or hit yourself
or whatever weird they've got
cooked up it's probably not not not
something worth looking into too much so
that's connecting to force structure
if you guys have more questions i could
do a few more of these really as we
start to get into finer and finer
variations of it it's just more
deceptive tricks
i think these three things pretty much
show you everything that you need to see
leverage is going to be the vast
majority of it there's some kind of
mechanical advantage going on leverage
is definitely something you need to know
about martial arts but can be used in
ways that are deceptive and and tell you
something else is going on other than
leverage right then force angle is
another really deceptive one that can
create all kinds of mysterious stuff a
woman made an entire career making
millions of dollars at the turn of the
century showing force angle stuff so
that is really deceptive but again just
a regular principle that can be used but
if someone selling it is something other
than force angle they're probably trying
to trick you and then connecting to
force structure or or connecting to
force is another one that you can use
that's used a lot of times by modern
magicians i've seen these things being
used by modern magicians today so
these three really encompass most of
what that stuff is
a lot of times too when you're seeing
people who are internal power experts
you should look at the person who is the
greatest
exemplar in the system if they are an ex
bodybuilder x power lifter x pro athlete
and they have all this amazing force
when they have all their people or these
tiny little people to demonstrate with
well that tells you they're probably
just a physically strong individual
so so you know be on the lookout for
this kind of stuff when people are
teaching these kinds of things they
should be telling you that it's it's a
simple skill uh and it's simple physics
and not just saying those words and then
and then not being able to explain how
it works they should then be able to
explain how it works so that's my uh my
little rant on this stuff so if you guys
have any more questions please let me
know but that's basically it i am
christopher hines joshua teehee my
icelander mcdaniel is behind that camera
right there is she giving you a winky
wonk all right we will see you guys next
time
foreign
[Music]